l'heure est grave de cette chose à part
le conseil de classe de gilles verdez je
vais me poser la semaine dernière la
semaine dernière je faisais 82 kg 4 avec
théo lundi dernier ce qui est très bien
j'étais pas été pareil
ouais mais la juge l'institut
eh bien écoutez je peux vous dire que je
n'ai pas bougé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est quoi cette honte là que j'ai fait
devancé de la france et dans l'ensemble
on regarde moi j'essayais c'est quoi et
quel est votre dernier repas par exemple
une dernière fois pas eu trop matches un
par un petit sandwich pas trop mal bamba
bon et la wii bras devant l'ordi la
maison il faut qu'ils vous concocter des
menus qu'un truc oui il est quoi la
bonne nouvelle c'est quoi n'hésitez pas
c'est que j'ai pas pris et là je dois
perdre en local qui l'ont d'une semaine
autant dire qu'on est bien là